the show actually has to look back and
surpass the 90s because unlike nearly
any other piece of pop culture this is a
show that has been
on for 30 years it's been on for
multiple generations hi again i'm jack
pacone host of the simpsons podcast
worst episode ever and this is part two
of every job homer has had on the
simpsons
[Music]
we're gonna define these jobs as
anything homer's done paid or unpaid
ranging from his main job at the nuclear
power plant to any of the many
one-off gags off-screen references and
whatnot over the course of 31 seasons
encountered
this guy in here owes us money leave
them to me
i hurt my fist and my palm season 18 is
actually the season that has the most
episodes where homer gets another job
when fat tony is shot and left in a coma
homer takes over as a mob boss it's only
a matter of time
he wear taco belly homer becomes a
mexican wrestler named taco belly
he was a mob boss might as well be a
mexican wrestler we're in season 18
folks
simpson's manly man handyman at your
service marge starts a carpentry
business
and uses homer as a front since most
people won't hire a woman
homer takes all the credit angering
marge who leaves him to rebuild a roller
coaster by himself which nearly gets him
killed
now where's my parade homer accidentally
signs up for the army and almost gets
himself killed during some exercises
this is very similar to when he did the
same thing in the navy and in the
reserves
season 20 is a very big transitional
period for the simpsons it's when it
moved from
a classic hand-drawn animation to hd
era this gave the writers a lot more
options and the show
at first subtly shifts tonally they
start taking more chances and it becomes
more avant-garde
[Applause]
they even slow down a bit in certain
episodes and basically when you tune in
week to week you don't know what you're
gonna get
now season 18 where we are now is kind
of the
end of the first era this is now where
they're not avant-garde they've almost
become a parody of themselves
and that's why there's so many homer
gets a job episodes in this season
after inadvertently killing an ice cream
truck driver homer takes the truck and
becomes a driver himself
this is very similar to when he did the
same thing with a plow truck and with a
freighter truck and
eventually we'll see he does it with a
tow truck uh homer likes trucks
[Applause]
to cheer marge up homer rebuilds the
boardwalk of her childhood vacation town
and then immediately burns it down by
accident to repay the town it becomes a
fisherman joining a fishing crew
lenore for sale get german
this is a mockumentary where we see
homer at various ages when he was
younger he had several jobs including
his first after-school job manure
salesman
additionally he's an infomercial actor
where he gets paid to ask questions and
infomercials and he's a character artist
for open coffin funerals did he have any
hobbies
i also wreck bar mitzvah after
accidentally photographing a celebrity
scandal and making a lot of money homer
becomes a tabloid paparazzo
a homer eventually gives up the gig in
exchange for celebrities treating their
fans with more respect
this is one of the first times where a
homer's job comes because something went
viral
i'll be a rep when lisa's soccer referee
quits homer takes a job because he hears
the players actually have to share their
stacks with him
dad where'd you get that outfit i got
fired from foot locker homer gets his
referee outfit from when he was fired at
foot locker at some point
i'll take five mattresses they don't
work here
you do now son when homer falls asleep
on a store model of a mattress and
actually ends up selling five of them
he gets hired to become a mattress
salesman
moment what the hell is that that's the
fire
silence homer crashes into a firehouse
and injures the entire fire department
so he becomes a firefighter while they
recover
he begins stealing from the house as he
saves before his family guilt him into
giving his loot to the homeless
this job is in the trend of homer
getting a job because he actually
injures or kills the person who had it
before
[Music]
homer becomes an opera star after dr
hibbert realizes that when he lies on
his back his stomach lodges underneath
his diaphragm and gives him a powerful
voice
after being stalked by a fan homer quits
and discovers his talent for painting
while on his back
the painting is more of a hobby that
comes on as a joke on the tail end of
the opera so we're not going to consider
it a separate job
ah my first toe homer becomes a tow
truck driver after befriending one in
the neighboring town
when he accidentally tows in their
territory homer is locked up in his
basement until marge breaks him out
at this point homer's driven ambulances
plow trucks regular trucks
so we might as well add tow truck to the
mix
man your work is a silhouette model for
one day and it haunts you for the rest
of your life
in this episode homer mentions he was
once a silhouette model for mud flaps
homer and marge are rival assassins in a
treehouse of horror parody of mr and mrs
smith
and like the previous treehouse of
horror we're counting this one as a job
just because the original
base story takes place in a springfield
that mostly resembles our own as opposed
to an alternate universe take on homer
pain is brown
hate is why rocker
in an infamous retcon that updates homer
and marge's early years from the 70s to
the 90s
homer is now a member songwriter
frontman for the grunge band sadgasm
homer becomes rich and famous but the
band breaks up before bart is born
this episode that 90s show is probably
the episode that finally made me feel
old
what's interesting about this episode is
the show initially defined the 1990s it
was
the 1990s and now that we've moved so
far away from that decade the show
actually has to look back it surpassed
the 90s
and it has to update the entire canon of
the show
for it to kind of make sense the 90s
never heard of it
horror and march started out as baby
boomers and now we're completely
retconning them to be generation x
the show goes on for another 10 years
homer and marge are gonna become
millennials
the show has actually been on so long
that the very nature of the stories it
tells in the world it takes place
in has changed quite like the real world
has i mean look back 10 seasons to when
homer had this
obscure internet company hey what the
huh the internet king i wonder if he can
provide faster nudity
so at this point the simpsons even have
smartphones
marinating with you is cool dang done
some of that is cow blood homer makes
his own homemade beef jerky they never
really say when this started happening
or where or why but when it comes to
food we don't ask questions with homer
stop in the name of a private citizen
with no connection to the law
homer you could have killed him i sure
could have
homer and ned become bounty hunters for
bail skippers and i remembered this
abandoned greenhouse outside of town
which used to be a beautiful thriving
greenhouse till i was hired to run it
homer helps take care of endangered bees
in an abandoned greenhouse for lisa and
later mates them with most killer bees
to make a hybrid species that can
survive
this weird phenomenon of bees dying off
really became
part of the cultural consciousness at
this point so the simpsons had no choice
but to bring it up somehow
ireland doesn't like pubs anymore this
isn't the first time homer's been a
bartender but it is the first time he's
been a bartender in ireland he and
grandpa get really drunk at a pub in
ireland and end up buying the place
to boost sales they allow smoking inside
when the show started in 1989
smoking in bars was actually very common
it wasn't until the 90s that it became
more and more illegal
so this is kind of a commentary on the
good old days when we could
choke on cigarette smoke inside a bar
[Music]
homer lands the lead role in a superhero
blockbuster film called
everyman he loses then gains back his
weight and the film flops
not only is this the first time homer's
been an actor but he's even been a
superhero before
one thing's for sure i'm not every man
i'm making you my new executive
assistant why can't i keep the job i
have now
whatever it is when carl becomes
supervisor at the power plant he chooses
homer to be his personal assistant
not only is this another job homer has
had to plan it's not even the first time
he's been somebody's assistant at the
power plant
let's give the olympics a miracle
and marge compete in the 2010 vancouver
olympics as olympic curlers
and while homer was a great softball
player in the work league and has worked
with a lot of famous athletes this is
the first time he himself is actually on
the field
or the ice or whatever they call it not
a big curler guy
what this guy hey
oh homer is arrested for bribing a city
official to clear up multiple fines and
to avoid prison he becomes an fbi
informant
going undercover in prison to
investigate fat toning they actually
bond and become friends and when fat
tony finds out homer's a rat he has a
heart attack and dies
the fat tony we see from here on out is
actually his identical cousin
fit tony who then gained a bunch of
weight and became fat tony your memory
is not deceiving you this is not the
first time
homer got in trouble and then became an
informant for the fbi
homer is the voice over actor for angry
dad in bart's oscar-nominated short film
this isn't the first time we've seen
homer as an actor and it's not even the
first time we've seen him as a voiceover
actor if you remember he was poochy
the name's booty d and i rocked the
telly i'm half joe camel and a third
bonzer alley
my time being wasted was not wasted
just two episodes later homer gets even
more acting experience replacing tommy
chong
on stage as part of a new comedy duo
cheech and chunk
i bet you didn't think when you saw this
list that chong would be one of the jobs
now how could someone as young as you
know about 20 years ago
after cutting selma's hair with garden
shears homer becomes the most popular
hairdresser in town
until hearing the constant gossip of his
women customers forces him to quit
hairdressing is kind of another way
homer has expressed himself artistically
throughout the run of the
show
homer once again becomes a superhero in
a non-canonical
diving bell on the butterfly parody
after being bitten by a spider and
completely paralyzed homer has to
communicate through farting then
he gets bit by a second spider this
one's radioactive
he shoots webs from his butt and becomes
a superhero
[Music]
if repeatedly rebooting homer as a
superhero isn't an example of the
simpsons as a fun house mirror to
society i don't know what it is
now i want a list of a hundred ways to
make your job worse by closing business
today
can one of the hundred be making the
list no homer gets an assistant at work
just like he did in season two
except instead of harry feierstein
i'll eat three weeks vacation and moving
expenses you got it buddy
now we have jane lynch this assistant
actually becomes homer's boss
when she rats him out to mr burns and
homer becomes her assistant
when homer and lisa find out that most
young adult fantasy novels are ghost
written by committee he decides to get
rich quick by putting together his own
writer's group and petting the troll
twins of underbridge academy
our book will be about an orphan who
goes to a
magical school where he discovers he's
a vampire this book eventually becomes a
success but all the credit is stolen by
author neil gaiman
ah gaming
[Music]
the higher their eyes the further they
fall you know
you're kind of a downer mr burns makes
homer an account executive after a video
of them karaoke
together goes viral with the new
corporate position homer becomes colder
and more distant from his family
this entire plot is heavily influenced
by mad men which was very much at the
forefront of pop culture at the time
welcome to gut check with homer simpson
where the truth is served
with a side of in your face
after a youtube video of homer ranting
goes viral homer is given his own
political cable show
he missed being full of crap after
choosing ted nugent to be the republican
presidential candidate
so not only is this another job that
homer gets from going viral but again it
plays on this evolution of how the show
treats politics
where once homer was kind of an
apolitical every man this is definitely
more about the actual polarization of
politics in the country red versus blue
republican versus democrat
homer specifically here is a
conservative pundit the republicans
are the ones that choose homer as their
face
i'm you jesus me so homer isn't actually
jesus christ here he's playing him in a
passion play
and he actually blows the audience away
with an amazing performance
until his weight crushes the cross and
he collapses
[Music]
speaking of jesus homer becomes a deacon
for the church for a new young hip
reverend played by edward norton who
wins homer over using a lot of pop
culture references
what jesus is saying really can be
explained by an episode of
californication
i'm not one for taking new jobs on a
whim but as we
say in the snowplow business i'm your
astronaut
barton flanders team up to get reverend
lovejoy back because bart actually
misses the time homer would spend at
[Music]
home
lisa gives a speech on her dad that
mentions the time he was a soccer ref
and it goes viral so he's actually
invited to brazil to be a ref at the
world cup
this is another job that homer gets
because he goes viral and you might have
noticed
now that we're seeing a dramatic
decrease in how many jobs homer works
per season and that's because the show
has really found its footing
in this new hd era where we're several
seasons in
and the storytelling and the types of
episodes we're seeing are more outside
the box more avant-garde
from week to week just complete
different tonal changes and they don't
need to rely as much
on the homer gets a job trope we're
seeing them focus on characters we
really haven't explored before
we're seeing them do formats and types
of shows we've never really seen before
at this point in season 24 25 26 the
poetic license of the show has expanded
so much that it doesn't need to rely on
tropes anymore
each week the simpsons kind of can do
whatever it wants and still be the
simpsons
[Music]
after buying a bass guitar homer forms a
cover band with kirk van houten reverend
lovejoy dr hibbert and a poo
when a poo breaks out on his own homer
becomes jealous and the band breaks up
this is yet another episode that homer
finds success as part of a band whether
it's the b
sharps sadgasm or archie bell and the
drells
night gathers and now my tough watch
begins
after duffman requires hip surgery homer
wins a reality show contest to become
the next duffman
the job requires homer to stay sober and
when he realizes the detrimental effects
of alcohol
he actually starts advocating people to
drink less which quickly gets him fired
and this job is actually a dream job for
homer it's the personification of
partying and drinking beer
so it's very ironic that once homer gets
it he realizes just how bad alcohol is
for you
this is one of those times where his
heart kind of prevails and he turns on
his job
he turns on his employers for the
greater good
dirty clean dirty clean
when lisa starts an app developing
company at home homer freaks out at the
burgeoning digital
age and relives simpler times by taking
his old job as a dishwasher at a greek
diner
unfortunately the job pays essentially
nothing this story might seem familiar
because homer actually did the same
thing
over a dozen years ago but even though
it's the same story on paper they're
in very different worlds with very
different things to say so when homer
started his internet company from home
he was kind of looking forward to this
brand new horizon
whereas now anybody can kind of develop
an app from home and homer has taken the
role of the reactive agent he is afraid
of new modern times and this is why he
regresses and goes back to an old job as
a dishwasher
and reflecting the world and reflecting
society uh the show's idea of the
internet has completely changed from
when homer did it when homer did it it
was this radical new way to make money
this kind of futuristic technology
and now coding and developing apps as a
day-to-day job it's it's very normal
it's a that's why
lisa an eight-year-old can even do it
that's the package
what package the package you're
delivering
at this point we've seen homer smuggle
sugar alcohol fruits and vegetables so
why not an exotic snake
oh dear i can't afford it
now homer's been an entertainer before
as either a musician or an actor or
voice over actor
so it really made sense for him to
become an improv comic because improv
comedy was really at its height around
now
we've been talking about how the show
has evolved in the way you tell stories
and the stories it tells
but we really haven't talked about how
it's evolved in animation technology and
this might be the pinnacle of it this
episode is very fascinating because at
the very end of the show
homer's voice actor dan castellaneta
actually improvises the final minutes of
the show he improvises his own scene
even taking
phone calls from viewers which is crazy
hello
joe homer how are you doing i'm doing
all right is that your question
i was wondering what kind of car do you
drive i said oh uh i drive a hybrid
which is a combination of old and
terrible
for both the east coast and the west
coast he performs twice
using kind of a pre-rendered homer but
with his mouth actually
matching dan castle at his mouth now
we've talked about how the show has
evolved in terms of
storytelling writing and the world it
exists in but this episode is
fascinating because it shows just how
far the show has come in terms of
animation technology
this would have been impossible 20 years
ago because it would be a terrible
strain on the animator's wrists
we had to do whatever it takes to get
you to leave when marge is arrested for
child negligence homer actually becomes
a guard at the prison to help her escape
now on its surface this might seem like
one of homer's law enforcement adjacent
jobs
but it's actually more in tune with his
illegal smuggling jobs because
he is trying to break somebody out of
prison
so the simpsons actually moved to boston
basically because homer falls in love
with candle bin bowling he gets a
similar job there as safety inspector
but at the new england candy factory
and the simpsons start to make a new
life in boston at least until homer
finds out that their football team
cheats this is yet another job homer
takes on because of his impulsiveness
basically because he likes the way the
pins are in boston homer next week we
finally take our revolutionary teeth
whitening strips to market
and another retcon of homer and marge's
early years this is when they're living
in capital city
and kind of working cool young hip jobs
and this is one of them for homer
that he loses sometime after bart is
born i have a question for you
on bones did you ever have any bones
with meat left on them and if so where
are those bones
homer and flanders make a movie for the
christian film market that earns over
100 million dollars at the box office
although homer doesn't end the episode
as a millionaire he ends up giving it
away to charity
between check this out the car is
driving by itself i'm a genius
after homer crashes into mr burns's
office and is fired he kind of gets the
perfect job
a tester for self-driving vehicles all
he has to do is sit there and let them
drive themselves
what's funny about this plot is when
they did the self-driving truck story
line in season 10
two decades ago it was a completely
far-fetched science fiction idea
now there really are startups for
self-driving vehicles so it kind of
makes sense that homer would end up
working for them again come on team bro
so at this startup homer and marge show
these overworked employees how to have
fun and end up getting hired to be the
employee fund managers this is kind of a
take on startup culture and how
employees are driven to just work very
long hours and not have any fun
i was on board until the shawarma
screamed very disappointing
lisa gives her tv recapping job to homer
because he watches a lot of tv
and he has a lot of fun with it until
krusty tries to run off the road for
giving him a bad review
you want to see something really humor
tv recapper is one of those jobs that
didn't really exist in season 10 so
we're not seeing it until season 30.
in an extended flashback sequence young
homer and marge actually work on a film
starring krusty
and homer works as a pa a production
assistant
esports coach homer coaches bart and
other conflict of enemies players in a
world championship held in seoul korea
this is a job and an industry that again
did not exist 20 years ago esports was
not a thing
and now it's extremely popular so it
would be remiss if the simpsons didn't
cover it at some point
you could literally play football
without any feet now we're in the most
recent season of the simpsons so we're
kind of seeing again
the same tropes but in a different light
this has homer's quick rise and fall
as well as homer going viral homer
having a knack for being a
solid entertainer a good front man and
it kind of all comes together here when
homer becomes a successful host on a
youtube type platform
listen up millenniums i'm homer simpson
your new supervisor
homer is demoted to this position and
rev lost count at how many different
positions he's had at the power plant at
this point
he's basically had them all besides
janitor which we'll probably see in
season 32's homer the janitor or
something
homer sells weed legally to clientele
who kind of miss the old way of doing
things the illegal dirtbag experience so
he starts selling it from the back of
moe's
lenny is on the floor playing video
games in a hoodie he kind of recreates
the old way of selling drugs
to make more money
and that's it that's each and every job
homer has had on the simpsons in the
first 31 seasons so the next 31 seasons
uh we'll get back to you
i have to go now my planet needs me